there hasn't been as much change as I
expected but we are continuing to have
some discussions tomorrow morning to
explore some of the technical issues
surrounding it and the meeting was
useful but inconclusive is the Prime
Minister accepting some of your what
were your red lines on a customs union
for example well we discussed this at
some length and I put forward the view
from the Labour Party that we want to
achieve a customs union with the
European Union we want to have accessed
the market and in particular we
discussed the dynamic regulatory
alignment that is guaranteed European
regulation is a minimum on particularly
environment as well as consumer and
employment rights so we did have a
discussion about all of that and this
will continue tomorrow at a technical
level when you looked into the Prime
Minister's eyes was she serious about
doing a cross-party deal she invited she
invited us to the meeting and I accepted
the meeting to go there to set out our
views she did put out with the
government's view but the whole thing
seems to depend on accepting the
withdrawal agreement as put forward at
the present time in a legislative forum
clearly that has to be taken together
with the future political Arrangements
declaration and we did spend some time
discussing that and explored some issues
around future trade agreements I've
raised the issue of your party's policy
on a public vote yes we did was raised
by me at the beginning of the meeting
and said look this is a policy of our
party that we would want to pursue the
option of a public vote to prevent
crashing out or prevent leaving on a bad
deal there was no agreement reached on
that we just put it there as one of the
issues that the Labour Party conference
voted on last year and therefore are you
open is she is the government's open to
the idea of an extension that is longer
than just may the 22nd that could
involve European parliamentary nations
if it goes beyond the 22nd of May then
clearly it does involve in voter appeal
actions which the government absolutely
does not want to be involved when they
made that very very clear the primary
has made that clear in the house as well
as in meetings with me and that is why
she is very keen to get a vote through
the house next week in order to get an
agreement with the EU which will mean
that Britain does not have to take part
in the EU elections the sheriff Ontario
emily Thorne papers have written to the
shadow cabinet and said that the
referendum issue must be on the table
that you shouldn't accept a deal with
the Prime Minister without that being on
the table is it a red line for you well
there was no deal offered and there's no
deal being offered by us either we just
discussed where we're at and she
reiterated where she is at at the
present time and so red lines in the
future didn't come up and you obviously
were in the house for that drama of the
tied vote there is a consequence to that
which means that the only indicative
votes process that might now happen is
if these talks don't succeed do you want
to see addictive votes on Monday I want
to see the house make a decision
hopefully in the direction that I would
want which is customs or a customs union
and protection of Rights as well as
access to trade it of course I want to
see that will put forward our views
again it won't be the same kind of
indicative vote processes last time
because this will be part of we assume
government legislation that has an awful
lot of talking to do before you reach
that position